la deuxième remarque un peu général que
je voudrais faire et se rapproche à ça
c'est quid de la france dans les
négociations internationales climat
alors je voulais dit l'énergie fossile
c'est le sait pouvoir d'achat et c'est
le niveau de vie jamais en fait quand
vous comprendrez les choses comme ça
jamais vous ne peuvent parvenir à la
conclusion que des hauts fonctionnaires
aussi méritants soit ils peuvent se
réunir quelque part dans le monde et
décidé de leur côté de niveau rationnel
de consommation des individus dans le
monde
ça peut pas marcher ça ne peut pas
marcher ce qui peut marcher c'est que
une région du monde parce qu'elle est le
dos au mur se lance dans cette affaire
de manière extrêmement résolue structuré
et massive
alors la raison pour laquelle j'ai
attiré votre attention ce matin sur la
particularité de la situation
énergétique de l'europe en matière de
carburant et de gaz
c'est parce que je vous dis l'europe est
le dos au mur elle y est donc notre
choix sans regret c'est de nous lancer
de manière résolue dans une économie qui
utilisent de moins en moins de
combustibles fossiles ça doit être ça
notre conquête de la lune et ça doit
nous occuper 40 ans et c'est pas une
transition à 100 milliards c'est une
transition à 5000 enfin calcul d'ordre
de grandeur
l'ordre de grandeur des investissements
qu'il faut consentir pour refaire les
villes refaire les infrastructures de
transport refaire le paysage agricole
parce que le paysage agricole qu'on a
fait aujourd'hui ne convient pas un
monde sous stress énergétique un camion
sur trois transporte quelque chose qui
se mange donc ça le paysage agricole
qu'on a organisé aujourd'hui ne convient
pas à une raréfaction significative de
l'approvisionnement énergétique refaire
tout ca c 40 ans et ses quelques
milliers alors je ne sais pas si c'est
4000 8000 ou dix mille milliards d'euros
mais pour moi c'est une très bonne
nouvelle ça veut dire qu'on a une
colonne vertébrale autour de laquelle il
doit nécessairement y avoir le même
consensus politique que pour le fait
d'avoir des caisses de retraite sinon
s'en sortira jamais et il faut que vos
divergences s'exprime à la marge sur des
petites manières des petits machins
concernant la gestion du problème
voilà un peu plus de marcher ici un peu
plus d'état voilà mais si ça va au delà
de ça ça marchera pas ça ne marchera pas
donc à un moment on a besoin de quelque
chose qui ressemble à une union
nationale sinon on va vers le bazar pour
tous extrêmement bien partagée mais je
ne suis pas sûr que vous ayez été élu
député pour vous occuper de ce genre de
choses